Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Mein Name ist Tim Pridlaff und ich begrüße alle hier zur 111.
Aufnahme von Raumzeit und ja, ich reise ja immer gerne im Rahmen dieses Podcasts
und hab schon den ein oder anderen Standort in Europa abgeklappert.
Eins fehlte mir auf jeden Fall noch und das war ein Standort in Genf.
Konkret befinde ich mich jetzt hier am Conseil Européen pour la Recherche Nucléaire.
So wie es eigentlich offiziell nicht mehr heißt, aber mal hieß und die Abkürzung
nach wie vor beibehalten hat, nämlich das CERN.
Also hier der Standort für Kernforschung und Europa, finde ich,
wird der Sache gar nicht so richtig gerecht.
Eigentlich ist es der internationale Standort für Kernforschung.
Was es genau ist und welche Bedeutung das hat, warum es das gibt,
das erzählt uns heute mein Gesprächspartner für heute, nämlich Manfred Krammer.
Hallo, herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit.
Ja, hallo. Ich freue mich auch, dass ich heute dabei sein kann.
Mein Name ist Manfred Gramer. Ich komme, wie man vielleicht aus meinem Dialekt hört, aus Wien.
Hört man. Genau. Und Sie sind Head of Experimental Physics Department. Schon länger?
Seit 2016, also etwas mehr als sieben Jahre, leite ich hier die experimentelle Abteilung.
Die sich um was genau kümmert? Also ich meine hier gibt es ja viele Leute,
die hier arbeiten. Ich weiß gar nicht wie viele Leute hier arbeiten mittlerweile beim CERN.
Ja gar nicht so viele. Vom CERN direkt bezahlt ungefähr 3500.
Aber zwischen 12.000 und 13.000,
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler aus der ganzen Welt betreiben hier ihre Forschung.
Sozusagen als Gast?
Wissenschaftler bezahlt von ihren Heimatinstituten, aber sie sind manche ihr
ganzes Leben, ihr ganzes Forschungsleben hier an Zern, andere kommen vielleicht
nur ein, zwei Wochen pro Jahr für Meetings.
Das Experimental Physics Department kümmert sich konkret wo drum?
Wir kümmern uns um die Infrastruktur. Wir helfen diesen Gastwissenschaftlern
hier ihre Experimente durchzuführen.
Das heißt, wir betreuen die Experimente, alle Experimente an Zern und meine
Abteilung ist natürlich an einigen, hauptsächlich natürlich an den großen Experten
direkt auch als Institut beteiligt.
Und das heißt Sie sind so ein bisschen auch die Schnittstelle zu diesen anderen
Wissenschaftlern sozusagen, vom internen Team nach außen.
Wir sind die Schnittstelle zu den internationalen Teams, wir sind aber auch
auf der anderen Seite die Schnittstelle zu den sehr internen Abteilungen.
Zur Maschine, zum Legal Service, zu den Human Resources, also wir sind sozusagen
die Schnittstelle für die User und die Experimente.
Alright, dann schauen wir doch vielleicht nochmal kurz auf Ihre persönliche
Geschichte. Wann hat es denn angefangen mit der Wissenschaft bei Ihnen?
Ja, ich habe in Österreich auf der Technischen Universität Technische Physik
studiert und bin relativ früh mit dem CERN in Berührung gekommen.
Ein Professor von mir hat mich für ein Praktikum empfohlen, aus dem dann eine
Diplomarbeit geworden ist.
Das war Anfang oder Mitte der 80er Jahre.
Nach kurzem Aufenthalt zurück in
Wien bin ich dann für meine Dissertation ebenfalls an den CERN gekommen.
Ja und damit war es um mich geschehen. Ich war sozusagen ein CERNOA und habe
dann den Rest meines Forschungslebens nicht direkt am CERN verbracht,
sondern bei einem Institut in Österreich, Institut für Hochenergiephysik,
Aber ich habe immer für Experimente am CERN gearbeitet.
Bin also sozusagen immer hin und her gebändelt, bis ich dann 2016 eingeladen
wurde, die Leitung des Physikdepartements zu übernehmen.
Schon eine große Ehre, oder?
Ist eine große Ehre und eine sehr, sehr interessante, abwechslungsreiche Aufgabe.
Kann ich mir vorstellen. Heute wollen wir ja so ein bisschen mal in Geschichte
und Wesen der Organisation einsteigen und ich kann auch gleich verraten,
das wird hier nicht die letzte Sendung sein, die ich vom CERN sende oder hier aufnehme,
sondern es wird eine ganze Reihe von Gesprächen geben, die hier ins Detail gehen,
insbesondere was die einzelnen Instrumente betrifft und wir wollen das halt
dann entsprechend noch vertiefen.
Das ist also jetzt in gewisser Hinsicht nur der Auftakt.
Und ja, jetzt müssen wir mal so ein bisschen in die Geschichte auch der Wissenschaft zurückrudern,
weil Kernforschung, klar, das war dann halt irgendwann mal ein Thema,
aber gab ja auch mal eine Zeit, da wusste man noch gar nicht,
dass es sowas gibt wie ein Kern.
Also konkret geht es ja hier um den Atomkern, die Atomkernforschung und das
ist ja sagen wir mal in dem Bereich auch wirklich der Ort für Grundlagenforschung.
Also sehr viel mehr Grundlagenforschung glaube ich als hier geht nicht.
Und wer sich vielleicht auch gewundert hat, warum ich das Thema überhaupt hier
in einen Podcast reinwerfe, der eigentlich ganz klar mit Raumfahrt angefangen hat.
Für mich ist so ein bisschen Zern Raumfahrt auf dem Boden, so wie Raumfahrt
ja auch oft so ein bisschen Zern in Space ist. Also nicht alles ist deckungsgleich,
aber sehr viel der Erkenntnislage wird ja im Weltall gewonnen.
Aber vieles wird eben auch teilweise hier gewonnen und letzten Endes arbeiten
beide Bereiche ja extrem an der Erforschung der Grundlagen.
Aber wann entstand denn überhaupt in der Wissenschaft die Notwendigkeit diese
Art von Forschung vorzunehmen?
Ja, vielleicht sollte man, wenn man über die Geschichte des CERN spricht,
auch die Motivation für die Gründung des CERN erwähnen.
CERN wurde 1954 gegründet, also nächstes Jahr feiern wir 70 Jahre.
Und eine der Hauptmotivationen für die Gründung war, den CERN als eine Art Integrationsprojekt
für westeuropäische Wissenschaftler zu gründen, kurz nach dem furchtbaren Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Da sah man darin eine Notwendigkeit. Der CERN war sozusagen eines der ersten
Integrationsprojekte in Europa.
Und als Forschungszweig hatte man, wie Sie schon erwähnt haben,
Kernphysik ausgewählt.
Und das war damals die Zeit, als man begonnen hat, kernphysikalische Untersuchungen
mit Beschleunigern durchzuführen.
Und daher wurde als erstes Gerät hier am CERN, aus heutiger Sicht ein relativ
kleiner Beschleuniger, das Synchrozyklotron, gebaut.
Das ist eine Maschine, die man heute als Museumsstück noch an dem Originalort besichtigen kann,
passt in eine Halle, ist ein großer Magnet, in dem Protonen auf gewisse Energien beschleunigt werden
und dann für kernphysikalische Untersuchungen zur Verfügung stehen.
Und damit hat man damals exotische Teilchen untersucht.
Diese hat man vorher in der kosmischen Strahlung gefunden. Die Erde wird ja
andauernd von der kosmischen Strahlung bombardiert, die größtenteils aus Protonen besteht.
Und diese Protonen erzeugen kernphysikalische Reaktionen in der Atmosphäre.
Und bei Untersuchung dieser, was dann bis zur Erde herunterkommt,
die langlebigen Teilchen, hat man Teilchen gefunden, die neu sind, die exotisch waren.
Das ist zum Beispiel das Myon, ein schwerer Verwandter des Elektrons,
beziehungsweise hat man dann Teilchen gefunden, die auch nicht in das damalige
sehr einfache Schema gepasst haben.
Aber natürlich, Untersuchungen der kosmischen Strahlung, das lässt sich sehr
schwer planen. Und wie ich bereits gesagt habe, nur die langlebigen Teilchen,
die bei diesen Reaktionen entstehen, kommen bis zur Erdoberfläche.
Daher war der nächste Schritt, man macht das kontrolliert mit Hilfe von Beschleunigern.
Aber gehen wir vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen zurück in der Wissenschaftsgeschichte,
weil das Tor für diesen ganzen Forschungsbereich und überhaupt das Verständnis
dieser Welten und das Bedürfnis das zu untersuchen begann ja im Prinzip erst so grob Anfang des 20.
Jahrhunderts. So als die großen Revolutionen angestoßen wurden in beide Richtungen,
Relativitätstheorie von Einstein, aber eben dann vor allem auch die ganzen Erkenntnisse
rund um die Quantenmechanik und dieses Bemühen der Wissenschaft überhaupt erstmal
sozusagen zu verstehen, wie man so schön sagt, was die Welt im Innersten zusammenhält.
Noch mal Goethe zitiert zu haben und das musste sich ja dann auch erst mal finden
und auch dieses Konzept von Strahlung,
Radioaktivität, also wann hat sich denn überhaupt das wissenschaftliche Bild
soweit geformt, dass man wusste womit man es zu tun hat?
Ich habe gar nicht so sicher mit den Experimenten von Rutherford,
Alpha-Strahlung auf Goldfolien.
Da hat man zum ersten Mal gesehen, dass es so etwas wie einen Kern geben muss,
dass die Materie durchlässig ist, aber aus Korpuskeln, aus Kernen besteht.
Ich würde sagen, das war der Beginn des Verständnisses, des Aufbaus der Materie.
Vorher hat man wahrscheinlich einen schwammigen Begriff von Materie gehabt,
aber zu dem Zeitpunkt hat man dann begonnen, Teilchen zu identifizieren.
Kerne und das erste Elementarteilchen und ein Elementarteilchen,
um das vielleicht zu erklären, ist ein Teilchen, das sich nicht weiter unterteilen
lässt, sozusagen mit unserem Wissen heute punktförmig ist.
Und das erste dieser Elementarteilchen war das Elektron, das man entdeckt hat
vor etwas mehr als 100 Jahren.
Und bis dahin gingen wir ja davon aus, dass das Atom das schon vielleicht sei,
weil das ja eigentlich der historische Name ist, der Unteralpakan.
Damals oder schon noch einige Jahre vorher glaubte man das Atom ist der kleinste
mögliche Baustein der Materie.
Aber war halt nicht so. Genau und dann ist halt daraus sozusagen die Erkenntnis
darüber langsam geworden, dass es eben Teilchen gibt, aber ich glaube man hat
am Anfang auch nicht im Ansatz damit gerechnet so viele unterschiedliche zu finden.
Man hat am Anfang ein paar Teilchen gefunden, man hat einen Kern gefunden,
hat festgestellt, der Kern besteht noch aus Protonen und Neutronen,
man hat das Elektron gehabt und eigentlich hätte das auch ausgereicht und reicht
auch aus, um das Biodensystem der Elemente zu erklären.
Und dann kam, was ich vorher vielleicht schon erwähnt habe, Untersuchungen,
dass der kosmischen Strahlung als plötzlich ein Teilchen auftauchte,
das Myon, das ähnliche Eigenschaften hat wie das Elektron, nur viel schwerer
war. Das hat gar nicht reingepasst.
Aber wie konnte man denn das, also was hat sich denn da technisch bereits entwickelt,
dass man das überhaupt messen konnte?
Es wurden die ersten Detektoren entwickelt, die solche Teilchenspuren nachweisen konnten.
Es gab damals die ersten Detektoren, die nicht nur nachweisen konnten,
dass es Strahlung gibt, sondern auch verschiedene Größen dieser Teilchen messen konnte,
wie Ablenkungen in einem Magnetfeld, Spuren und daraus konnte man dann schließen,
dass es sich um ein anderes Teilchen handelt als das Elektron.
Und dann gab's ja dann diesen Pfad dahin, dass man irgendwie gesagt hat,
ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, wie so die Abfolge war, aber ein Teilchen kommt
dazu, das Myon kommt dazu, also irgendwann bestand ja sozusagen dieser Bedarf
mit, okay wir müssen das Feld neu sortieren.
Wir müssen hier in irgendeiner Form ein neues Konzept finden.
Man kam so vom Atom, das dann auf einmal aus Teilen bestand und jetzt muss ja
quasi die Formel wieder neu aufgestellt werden.
Ja, die Physik und im Speziellen natürlich, was wir jetzt Teilchenphysik nennen,
ist ein Wechselspiel zwischen Theorie und Experiment.
Die Experimentatoren messen etwas, finden etwas Neues, messen eine Abweichung
und dann gibt es Theoretiker, die das versuchen zu erklären,
die daraus ein Modell basteln, um das zu erklären.
Umgekehrt kann es natürlich auch sein, dass Theoretiker ein Modell aufstellen
und dann etwas vorhersagen, nachdem die Experimentatoren suchen und es entweder
beweisen oder falsifizieren.
Also es ist ein Ping-Pong-Spiel zwischen Experimenten und Theoretikern und dieses
Ping-Pong-Spiel hat langsam zur Entwicklung eines Modells, einer Theorie geführt,
die wir jetzt das Standardmodell der Teilchenphysiker nennen.
Begonnen hat es natürlich sehr einfach.
Ein paar einfachen Teilchen und Theorien, die das erklären konnten.
Dann fand man etwas, was da nicht hineinpasst.
Dann haben wieder ein paar sehr clevere Theoretiker ein anderes Modell vorgeschlagen,
das aber auch Vorhersagen gemacht hat. Und da sind wir dann schon in der Zeit
des Zern und der Teilchenphysik mit Beschleunigern.
Denn diese Vorhersagen konnten dann zum ersten Mal einen Beschleuniger überprüft werden.
Zum Beispiel mit dem Synchrozyklotron am CERN konnte eine gewisse Theorie zur
Fall von Pionen das erste Mal gemessen werden und somit ein Teil,
was wir jetzt das Standardmodell nennen, bewiesen werden.
Ich würde gerne mal diesen Gedankengang versuchen nachzuvollziehen,
warum man jetzt sozusagen auf Beschleunigung kam.
Also man versucht ja zu beobachten. Man hat jetzt durch verschiedene Experimente,
wie das erwähnte Rutherford Experiment, also erstmal rausgefunden,
okay da strahlt was und so wie wir das beobachten, passt das mit unserer bisherigen
Theorie nicht mehr zusammen. Es muss sozusagen Teilchen geben.
Was ist denn dann sozusagen die Entwicklungskette da in der in der Theorie und
in der Praxis und in der Technik gewesen zu sagen wir müssen jetzt irgendwas
beschleunigen um hier näher an die Wahrheit zu kommen?
Die Beschleuniger brauchen wir.
Teilchen zu erzeugen, die eine höhere Masse haben.
Je stärker die Energie ist, die wir im Beschleuniger erzeugen können,
umso schwerere, massereichere Teilchen können wir erzeugen. E ist gleich im
c², die berühmte Formel.
Und als offensichtlich war, dass es schwerere Teilchen geben muss,
hat man begonnen, immer größere Beschleuniger zu bauen. Und tatsächlich mit
jedem neuen Beschleuniger, der ein neues Energiespektrum eröffnet hat,
hat man wirklich was Neues gefunden.
Das ging sehr lange so.
Aber warum muss die Masse, also wie geht der Gedankenschluss zu diesem Ansatz?
Ich habe das schon erwähnt, dass sich wie ein Elektron erhält,
nur eine größere Masse hat.
Ähnliche Teilchen hat man bei
den Hadronen gefunden, also Teilchen die aus Quarks zusammengesetzt sind.
Also das was den Atomkern ausmacht.
Kern auch ausmacht. Das sind Atomkern, besteht aus Neutronen und Protonen, das sind Hadronen.
Dann kennen wir aber auch sogenannte Mesonen, die bestehen ebenfalls aus Quarks,
aus zwei Quarks und davon gibt es auch eine ganze Reihe.
Das erste Teilchen, das man kennengelernt hat, war das sogenannte Pion und dann
hat man ein Teilchen gefunden, das Kaon, das sich wiederum ähnlich verhalten
hat als das Bion, aber schwerer war, wie wir jetzt wissen, weil es ein schwereres Quark enthält.
Und um diese von Bionen auf Kaonen, um das immer weiter zu untersuchen,
hat ein Beschleuniger mit immer höheren Energien gebraucht.
Also was macht das Prinzip der Beschleunigung? Wie kam man überhaupt darauf,
dass man einen Beschleuniger braucht?
Das so ein bisschen versuche ich gerade herauszufinden.
In der Analogie, ich denke jetzt, das ist natürlich lang vor meiner Zeit gewesen,
ich denke natürlich in der Analogie zur kosmischen Strahlung.
Wir wissen ja, kosmische Strahlung hat sehr hohe Energie, wusste man damals sicher auch.
Die kosmische Strahlung trifft auf die Atome, Atomkerne der Gashülle und wenn
man das nachvollziehen möchte im Labor braucht man natürlich Beschleuniger,
um Protonen auf höhere Energie zu bringen, um dieses Phänomen der kosmischen
Strahlung nachvollziehen zu können unter kontrollierten Bedingungen.
Das gibt mir auch die Gelegenheit auf eine andere Sendung zu verweisen,
die ein bisschen mit diesem Thema zusammenhängt, Raumzeit 104.
Da geht es um das Cherenkov Teleskop Array, was ja auch die kosmische Strahlung
versucht zu analysieren und dabei eben konkret diesen Effekt,
diese Cherenkov Strahlung auswertet, während die kosmische Strahlung auf die
Atmosphäre der Welt, der Erde auftaucht und dort halt Lichtspuren hinterlässt,
die in diesem Fall von diesem Array gemessen werden.
Und das ist im Prinzip das, was man im Beschleuniger versucht nachzubauen.
Hier liegt die Masse zwar rum, aber sie ist halt nicht schnell und wenn man
sie irgendwie beschleunigen will, muss man sie halt irgendwie auf Trab bringen.
Das heißt, das sind wir jetzt sozusagen in der Zeit kurz vor CERN.
Das war sozusagen die Erkenntnis.
Es wurden erste Beschleuniger-Systeme gebaut in einem sehr überschaubaren Raum
und man hat einfach gesehen,
okay, jetzt haben wir hier schon eine ganze Halle voll gebaut oder wie groß
die ersten Beschleuniger auch immer gewesen seien, mögen wir brauchen das jetzt mal in größer.
Ja der erste Beschleuniger wie ich schon gesagt habe passt noch in eine Halle.
Parallel dazu wurde aber auch der nächste Beschleuniger schon geplant und mit
dem Bau begonnen. Das ist das Proton Synchrotron.
Das hat immerhin schon einen Umfang von fast 800 Meter und damit hat man jetzt
dann natürlich deutlich höhere Energien erreicht und konnte damit Teilchen studieren,
die noch höhere Massen haben.
Das Prinzip war damals das sogenannte Fixed-Target-Experiment-Prinzip.
Man hat hauptsächlich Protonen in diesen Beschleunigern auf hohe Energien gebracht
und diese dann auf ein Target geschossen.
Das Target ist ein Materieblock, das kann Blei sein,
Eisen sein, aber auch Wasserstoff, Gas und hat dann untersucht,
welche Wechselwirkungen, welche Reaktionen diese hochenergetischen Protonen
in dem Target verursachen.
Indem man nach dem Target die Detektoren aufgebaut hat. dann konnte man die
Teilchen untersuchen, die bei den Reaktionen entstehen.
Und das BS, das ebenfalls Ende der 50er Jahre gebaut wurde, ist noch immer im Betrieb.
Es ist ein Vorbeschleuniger jetzt vom großen LHC, zu dem wir sicher noch sprechen kommen.
Also diese Maschine ist nach einigen Verbesserungen aber immer noch im Betrieb.
Dann münden wir doch mal sozusagen in die konkrete Entstehungsgeschichte ein.
Also die Wissenschaft hat sozusagen erstmal festgestellt, gut,
Kernforschung ist wichtig, weil das ist etwas, was uns überhaupt erstmal die
Grundlagen bringt, Physik überhaupt zu verstehen und die offenen Fragen zu beantworten.
Und mit den Grundlagen, die so in den 30er Jahren gelegt wurden,
theoretischer Natur und dann praktischer Natur, kann man dann eben schnell auf
diesen Punkt so beschleunigen, sind ein wenig der Schlüssel zur Erkenntnis.
Das würde ich mal so festhalten.
Also es ist jetzt nicht nur so irgendeine Technologie,
sondern es ist schon so eine richtige Schlüsseltechnologie, die wirklich dazu
beitragen kann, diesen Teilchen zu überhaupt erstmal zu kartieren und dann eben
auch daraus Schlüsse zu ziehen, was gehört jetzt hier eigentlich zu was,
was hat worauf einen Einfluss, was besteht aus was.
Also Beschleuniger sind nicht irgendwas, sondern Beschleuniger sind sozusagen essentiell.
Und das ist dann das, was letzten Endes, gerade eben nach dem Krieg,
sozusagen das verbindende Element war,
wo man gesagt hat, okay es ist jetzt Zeit für ein wirklich großes wissenschaftliches
Gesamtexperiment und einen neuen Standort und dann eben in dem Zuge vielleicht
auch noch so ein Friedensprojekt,
um an dieser Stelle die Grundlage zu schaffen für die weitere wissenschaftliche Forschung.
Kann man das so stehen lassen? Ja, ja.
Dann sind wir jetzt sozusagen in den 50er Jahren. Womit fing es denn hier an?
Deswegen, wie ich schon gesagt habe, mit dem ersten kleineren Beschleuniger
an, mit den ersten kernphysikalischen Experimenten.
Wie gesagt, den Begriff Hochenergiephysik, Teilchenphysik, hat es damals sicherlich noch nicht gegeben.
Dann die nächste Maschine, um zu höheren Energien zu kommen,
war der Proton-Synchrotron.
Damit konnten dann Teilchen erzeugt werden, die deutlich höhere Energien haben.
Die wurden in der Zwischenzeit bei anderen Forschungseinrichtungen entdeckt,
wie zum Beispiel das Chum-Teilchen in Amerika, Reaktionen, wo diese Teilchen
mit ins Spiel kommen konnten, dann am CERN ebenfalls untersucht werden.
Die Erkenntnis kam dann im Wechselspiel, wie ich bereits gesagt habe,
mit der Theorie, dass es noch schwerere Teilchen geben musste.
Dann schon langsam die Erkenntnis gekommen, dass man zur Erklärung der Phänomene,
die wir sehen, es mehr als diese drei, vier damals bekannten Quarks,
wir reden jetzt hauptsächlich von Quarks, geben muss.
Und daher hat man dann begonnen, einen noch größeren Beschleuniger am CERN zu
bauen. Jetzt sind wir am Anfang der 70er Jahre. Das ist das sogenannte SPS.
Das war dann immerhin immerhin bereits ein Beschleuniger mit ungefähr 7 km Umfang,
der wiederum noch immer benützt wird als Vorbeschleuniger für den LHC.
Jetzt muss ich nochmal ein bisschen auf die Technik als solche zu sprechen kommen,
damit auch alle das nachvollziehen können. Bei so Beschleuniger hört man halt
immer so, okay, alles klar, wir beschleunigen jetzt hier so die Teilchen.
Das macht man ja nicht eben so mit Haushaltsgerät.
Man nimmt also irgendein Atom oder ein Teil davon und will den jetzt sozusagen
auf die Reise schicken. Man will hohe Geschwindigkeiten erzeugen.
Jetzt nimmt man ja nicht eine Zwille, sondern man muss ja in irgendeiner Form
sowas leiten und es handelt sich ja immer um etwas extrem kleines.
Was sind also sozusagen die Grundkomponenten, die man braucht,
um diese Beschleunigung überhaupt zu erreichen?
Ja zum einen muss ich das widersprechen, man macht es auch mit Haushaltsgeräten.
Tatsächlich. zumindestens die Zuhörer, die noch einen Röhrenfernseher zu Hause
haben, das ist ein einfacher Beschleuniger.
Die Elektronen werden in der Röhre beschleunigt und treffen dann den Schirm
und erzeugen den Lichtblitz. Ein einfacher Beschleuniger.
Durch Anlegen eines elektrischen Feldes werden Elektronen beschleunigt.
Das ist das Grundprinzip eigentlich, nachdem auch die großen Beschleuniger funktionieren.
Auch hier erzeugen wir ein elektrostatisches Feld.
Und in diesem Feld, bei Durchlaufen des Feldes, werden die geladenen Teilchen,
egal ob es jetzt Elektronen oder Protonen sind, beschleunigt.
So, das ist das einfache Prinzip eines Linearbeschleunigers.
Jetzt, Linearbeschleuniger hat natürlich das Problem, dass man die Teilchen,
dass er sehr lang werden kann.
Und daher ist man übergegangen, Kreisbeschleuniger zu bauen.
Und um geladene Teilchen auf einem Kreis zu halten, braucht man Magneten.
Ein geladenes Teilchen, das fliegt, beschleunigt wird, würde nur geradeaus fliegen.
Jetzt brauche ich einen Magneten, um die Teilchen auf eine Kreisbahn zu zwingen.
Und dann kann ich die Teilchen durch dieses elektrostatische Feld bei jeder
Umdrehung durchschicken.
Ich habe also eine Beschleunigungsstrecke und die Teilchen fliegen da zigmal
in der Sekunde durch und werden zu immer höheren Energien beschleunigt.
Das ist der Prinzip eines Kreisbeschleunigens. Also ich brauche ein elektrostatisches
Feld und Magneten, die die Teilchen auf einer Kreisbahn halten.
Die Energie ist jetzt beschränkt durch die Energie, die ich zuführen kann durch
das elektrostatische Feld, aber auch durch die Abstrahlung, die Teilchen produzieren,
wenn sie auf einer Kreisbahn fliegen.
Ein Teilchen, das in eine Kreisbahn gezwungen wird, strahlt Energie ab,
die ich wieder zuführen muss.
Das kann ich jetzt insofern umgehen, als ich immer mehr Energie zuführe oder
den Ring größer machen, damit weniger abgestrahlt wird.
Das ist das Wechselspiel zwischen Größe eines Beschleunigers,
elektrostatisches Feld und dann auch Magnetfeld.
Das ist der Grund, warum, wenn ich zu höheren Beschleunigern komme,
möchte ich zu höheren Energien kommen, weil ich immer größere Ringe brauche.
Also ein klassisches Bigger is better Ding.
Wenn ich jetzt das Magnetfeld brauche, um das Teilchen erstmal so in die Bahn
zu zwingen, was macht das Teilchen schneller? Also was sorgt für die eigentliche Beschleunigung?
Die Teilchen müssen ein Spannungspotential durchlaufen.
In dem Spannungspotential werden sie dann beschleunigt. Also ich lege an der
Batterie einen Volt an, wenn ein Teilchen durchfliegt, gewinnt es die Energie von einem Elektrovolt.
Jetzt deswegen ist es natürlich sehr wenig, wir wollen ja auf Gigaelektronen,
Voltärelektronen kommen. Und da gibt es das Prinzip der Kavitäten.
In Kavitäten entstehen stehende Wellen, die ein elektrostatisches Feld erzeugen,
das die Teilchen beschleunigt.
Diese Gravitäten wurden auch so um die 50er, 60er Jahre entwickelt.
Natürlich werden jetzt immer besser, immer effizienter, werden superleitend.
Und das sind die Beschleunigerstrecken, die es zum Beispiel in LHC an einer
Stelle entlang des Ringes gibt.
Und die Protonen jedes Mal, wenn sie bei dieser Stelle vorbeikommen,
bekommen sie Energieschub.
Das sind diese Hohlraumresonatoren.
Okay, also über Resonanzen werden die Emel beschleunigt.
Genau, beschleunigt und damit Energie zugeführt. Wir führen ja Energie zu.
Das ist sozusagen die Technologie, die dann am CERN wirklich primär nach vorne gebracht wurde.
Und wann haben sich denn das erste Mal dann auch konkrete Erkenntnisse daraus,
aus dieser Arbeit ableiten lassen?
Ja, vielleicht der erste Meilenstein, wenn man so will, oder die erste große
Entdeckung am CERN war die Entdeckung der neutralen Ströme.
Wir haben hier auf der einen Seite die Quarks und Leptonen, also die Teilchen,
die Materieteilchen, aber diese Teilchen müssen ja miteinander interagieren,
sonst wäre das Universum sehr einfach und fad sozusagen.
Und da kennen wir vier Grundkräfte, elektromagnetische Kraft,
schwache Kernkraft, starke Kernkraft und die Gravitation.
Und bei der schwachen Kernkraft war nicht klar oder war nicht sicher,
ob es auch einen sogenannten neutralen Strom gibt, also eine Wechselwirkung,
bei der keine Ladung ausgetauscht wird.
Und der Nachweis für diesen neutralen Ströme wurde hier am CERN mit Hilfe des
PS-Beschleunigers in einer sogenannten Blasenkammer erbracht.
Das war der erste, würde ich sagen, große Entdeckung am CERN.
War eigentlich nur der Anfang für ein wirklich besseres Verständnis dieser schwachen Wechselwirkung.
Der Beweis, dass es einen neutralen Strom gibt, fordert auch,
dass es ein Austauschteilchen gibt für diesen neutralen Strom.
Das nennen wir jetzt das Z-Boson.
Und genau dieses Z-Boson wurde dann ungefähr 20 Jahre, 15 Jahre später,
hier am CERN ebenfalls entdeckt.
Mit dem nächsten Beschleuniger.
Um es gleich mal, um ein paar Leute noch mitzunehmen, weil man kommt ja hier
schnell ins Schlingern in dieser ganzen Begriffswelt.
Also Quarks, Leptonen, grob gesagt Quarks so ein bisschen das was so die Grundlage
für die Atomkerne darstellt, Leptonen ist quasi mehr so die Elektronenwelt,
beides zusammen macht ja so die Atome aus.
Und die vier Kräfte sind ja, ich frage ab und zu mal so Leute nach den vier
Grundkräften und es ist gar nicht so, wie soll ich sagen, also Gravitation hat
jeder schon mal gehört, beim Rest gibt's unterschiedliche Antworten.
Schwache Kernkraft ist halt so ein bisschen die Treibkraft hinter der Radioaktivität,
das was irgendwie sozusagen auch in der Lage ist so die Atome wieder zu zersetzen,
die ja ansonsten sehr stabil sind.
Die starke Kernkraft hält alles zusammen und die elektromagnetische Kraft ist
ja sagen wir mal die bekannteste, das ist so das was uns hier irgendwie ermöglicht
am Tisch zu sitzen und nicht in tausend Strahlen zu zerfließen. Das.
Heißt...
Diese erste Erkenntnis war vor allem erstmal eine Erforschung dieser schwachen Kraft,
primär, die einem viele Rätsel aufgegeben hat und überhaupt die Radioaktivität
auch so ein bisschen am Anfang der ganzen Idee des Teilchen Zoos auch stand.
Was hat dann diese Erkenntnis der neutralen Ströme klar gemacht?
Also war das sozusagen eine Erfüllung einer lang gepflegten Theorie und wo man
sich schon immer gedacht hat, das müsste so sein oder war das dann so revolutionär
mit so oh hoppala ist ja ganz anders als wir gedacht haben?
Nein, parallel dazu wurde eine Theorie entwickelt, die sowohl die elektromagnetische
Kraft als auch die schwache Kraft als die Erscheinung einer einzelnen Urkraft erklärt.
Also sozusagen die beiden Kräfte in einem mathematischen Konzept,
in einer mathematischen Theorie, die wir jetzt die elektroschwache Theorie nennen, zusammenfasst.
Und in dieser Theorie braucht man eben diese neutralen Ströme.
In dieser Theorie gibt es drei Austauschteilchen.
Wir stellen uns ja die Wechselwirkung der Kräfte so vor, indem sie Teilchen austauschen.
Das bekannteste Teilchen, sicher für jeden Hörer bekannt, ist das Photon.
Es tauscht die elektromagnetische Kraft aus. Für die schwache Kraft gibt es
jetzt die W- und die Z-Bosonen.
Also zusammen brauchen wir drei
dieser Austauschteilchen, um die elektroschwache Kraft zu beschreiben.
Damit sie überhaupt miteinander interagieren kann und nicht vollständig separat voneinander agiert.
Genau.
Ja das ist sozusagen die Suche nach den Bosonen.
Also diese, genau, Photon ist glaube ich sehr bekannt, weil ich meine das macht
das Licht, deswegen auch der Name.
Aber das Licht halt letzten Endes ja auch nur Elektromagnetismus ist,
ist glaube ich mittlerweile allgemein bekannt.
Und die anderen wechselwirkenden Teilchen,
also die, die sozusagen, kann man das sagen, so Quarks und Leptonen ist mehr
so das Ist und die Wechselwirkungen, also die Bosonen, die sind mehr so das,
was wird und sich ändert.
Mit einem leichten philosophischen Touch kann man das vielleicht so sehen.
Wir nennen es auf der einen Seite sind es die Materie Teilchen,
also das was sie als ist bezeichnen und das andere ist die Wechselwirkung zwischen
den Teilchen, ebenfalls ausgetauscht durch diese Posonen, das sind ebenfalls Teilchen.
So das heißt mit dieser Entdeckung wurde erstmal klar,
es gibt überhaupt erstmal eine unmittelbare Beziehung zwischen diesen beiden Kräften,
von denen man weiß, dass es sie gibt, die man messen konnte, beschreiben konnte,
für die die Theorie auch da war, die Beobachtungen gepasst haben,
nur ob sie komplett separat voneinander existieren oder dann doch irgendwas
miteinander zu tun haben, das war dann sozusagen diese Entdeckung, die dann,
Haben Sie es gesagt, ein neutraler Strom, der keinen Ladungsaustausch vornimmt.
Wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Also nachgewiesen wurde es, indem durch das Proton-Synchrotron am CERN wurden Neutrinos erzeugt.
Das sind Leptonen, gehören zur Klasse der Elektronenmyonen und so weiter.
Sie haben die Eigenschaft, dass sie keine Ladung haben, extrem leicht sind.
Wir wissen gar nicht wie leicht.
Wir haben noch keine Messung, praktisch durch alle Materie durchgehen,
denn sie wechseln wirkend nur schwach.
Und mit einem solchen Neutrinostrahl, Myon-Neutrinostrahl, den man hier erzeugt
hat, das hat man dann auf ein Target geschossen, in einer Blasenkammer,
und hat dort Wechselwirkungen mit den dort vorhandenen Elektronen gesehen.
Und zwar so, dass sich die Elektronen nicht umgewandelt haben,
sondern einfach gestreut wurden.
Also es war eine Wechselwirkung, ein Myon Neutrino geht rein,
trifft ein Elektron und man sieht ein Myon Neutrino auf der anderen Seite rauskommen,
ebenfalls mit einem Elektron. Also kein Austausch von Ladung.
Vermittelt durch die sogenannten Z-Bosonen. Aber der Beweis,
dass diese Theorie stimmt, ist erst erfolgt durch die Entdeckung dieser Z-Bosonen, 1983 am SPS.
Was heißt das jetzt, dass man die entdeckt? Also man baut jetzt seinen Beschleunigerring,
man schafft es halt, Teilchen auf hohe Energien hochzufahren,
in dem der Ring schön groß ist, die Magnetfelder entsprechend stark sind und
die Hohlraumresonatoren ihrer Arbeit leisten.
Das Teilchen fliegt, hat sehr viel Energie, aber wie kann ich jetzt sozusagen
diese Erkenntnis aus dieser Beschleunigung herausziehen?
Man bringt die Teilchen zu einer Wechselwirkung. Also man schießt,
wie ich schon gesagt habe, die Protonen zum Beispiel auf ein Target und dann
untersucht man, was rauskommt.
Man misst alle Teilchen, die bei der Reaktion entstehen.
Man misst, in welchem Winkel sie entstehen, man wisst, welche Teilchenart,
mit welchem Impuls sie entstehen, wie häufig gewisse Reaktionen stattfinden,
weil nicht jede Reaktion ist gleich.
Und das vergleicht man dann mit der Theorie, vergleicht man mit den theoretischen
Vorhersagen. Und im besten Fall stimmt das natürlich überein.
Wie viel Prozent sind denn hier Theoretiker und wie viel Prozent sind denn hier
so die Experimentalphysiker.
Weil das ist ja immer so der Witz bei den Physikern, dass so die Theoretiker
und die Experimentalphysiker so ein bisschen separate Türme sind,
die auf unterschiedlichen Inseln wohnen.
Aber hier kommt dann wirklich alles zusammen.
Ja, wobei der CERN ein experimentelles Labor ist,
also ich leite ja das Department für experimentelle Physik, ich habe knapp tausend
Leute in meinem Department, während die Theoriegruppe ist ungefähr einen Faktor 10 kleiner.
Aber es gibt sie.
Es gibt sie natürlich, ist sehr wichtig und diese Theoriegruppe arbeitet natürlich
mit den vielen tausenden Theoretikern auf der ganzen Welt zusammen.
Also ich traue mir jetzt keine Aussage treffen, ob es mehr Theoretiker oder
Experimentalphysiker gibt. Ich glaube es gibt mehr Experimentalphysiker,
aber im Großen und Ganzen hätte sich das schon sehr die Waage.
Aber die gehen auch gemeinsam Mittagessen. Die vertragen sich schon.
Ja, natürlich. Wir arbeiten ja zusammen. Wir versuchen ja gemeinsam die Rätsel
der Natur zu entziffern. Für Theoretiker macht es keinen Sinn eine Theorie zu
entwickeln, die keiner überprüfen kann.
Und für uns Experimentalphysiker macht das ja auch keinen Sinn,
etwas zu messen, wenn wir keinen Anhaltspunkt haben, was soll jetzt eigentlich
herauskommen laut Theorie. Das heißt wir brauchen einander.
Kommen wir wieder zurück zu der Weiterentwicklung des CERNs.
Also nach diesem ersten Durchbruch, was hat denn das bewirkt?
Also was, wie kann man sich denn das so vorstellen, was war denn so die Wirkung dieser Entdeckung,
dieser neutralen Ströme auf einerseits die wissenschaftliche Öffentlichkeit
weltweit, auch die Legitimation des Projektes in der Politik?
Wie muss man sich das vorstellen? War das so ein Heureka-Moment oder hat man schon mit gerechnet?
Ich glaube nicht, dass es ein Heureka-Moment war, denn man darf nicht vergessen,
das waren ganz andere Zeiten.
Informationsfluss war viel langsamer, es gab natürlich kein Internet,
neue Erkenntnisse haben sich nur langsam herumgesprochen über Publikationen,
Das hat sicher Monate gedauert, bis es publiziert war, andere Forscher gelesen haben.
Also der Erkenntnisgewinn und die Informationenverbreitung damals war natürlich
viel, viel langsamer, als es heutzutage ist.
Inwieweit die Politik damals Notiz genommen hat von den Entdeckungen und Arbeiten
an CERN, ja, bin ich mir nicht allzu sicher.
Aber natürlich, ich denke, nachdem der CERN ja dann weiter Zukunft hatte und
größere Projekte beschlossen wurden, dass es natürlich sehr positiv gesehen
wurde von den Mitgliedsländern.
Parallel dazu, muss man auch sagen, hat sich ja die Mitgliedschaft am CERN weiterentwickelt.
Gegründet wurde der CERN von zwölf europäischen Mitgliedsländern.
Mittlerweile haben wir 21 Mitgliedsländer und etliche assoziierte Mitglieder.
Das heißt auch die Community und die Anzahl der Mitgliedsländer im CERN hat
sich ja mit den immer größer werdenden Projekten auch erweitert.
Mir fällt auch grad so ein bisschen ein, in meiner Wahrnehmung,
es war jetzt auch nicht gerade meine Jugendzeit, so die 50er, 60er Jahre,
aber die waren ja einfach auch extrem geprägt von einem Glauben des technischen
Fortschritts und Aufbruchs und insbesondere die Atomtechnologie spielte da ja eine große Rolle.
Mal abgesehen jetzt von den.
Militärischen Entwicklungen, Kernkraftwerke, unbegrenzte Energieversorgung,
das war ja alles solche Träume,
die dort aktiv ausgelebt wurden,
überall wurden entsprechende Kernkraftwerke auch gebaut und es war generell
ja auch so ein Zustand der,
Ich würde fast sagen auch Dankbarkeit für wissenschaftlichen Fortschritt,
der ja nun gerade in der ersten Hälfte des 20.
Jahrhunderts dazu beigetragen hat, auch viele konkrete Probleme der Welt von
Ernährung bis hin zu Transport zu lösen und fundamental voranzubringen.
Also innerhalb von 50 Jahren hat sich ja die Welt enorm verändert,
vielleicht so sehr wie seitdem auch nie wieder.
Gut Internet ist jetzt nochmal vielleicht in eine andere Dimension und in gewisser
Hinsicht sehen wir ja auch immer noch eine exponentielle Beschleunigung in manchen
Bereichen, aber sagen wir mal was so das Leben an sich der Leute betrifft hat
sich ja wirklich sehr viel verändert.
Und das war ja dann auch so ein bisschen das Vertrauen, was in so ein großes
wissenschaftliches Experimentsystem reingesteckt wurde.
Diese Aufbruchstimmung und diese Technologie, glaube ich, war damals sicher präsent.
Obwohl im Namen des CERN Kernphysik vorkommt, hat sich der CERN aber relativ
rasch zu wirklich der fundamentalen Grundlagenforschung entwickelt.
Hier am CERN wurde nie Kernphysik an sich betrieben.
Ich muss jetzt vorsichtig sein, wir haben nämlich einige Einrichtungen hier
am CERN, wo wir sehr wohl kernphysikalische Untersuchungen machen.
Aber am CERN wurde nie an Atomkraftwerken und schon gar nicht an irgendwelchen
Militärforschungen, Das wurde ja von vornherein ausgeschlossen,
in der Konvention gearbeitet.
Also der CERN hat sehr früh wirklich die fundamentalen Fragen versucht zu beantworten,
was die Welt, wie Sie gesagt haben, innestens zusammenhält.
Und daher, der CERN wurde, glaube ich, schon eher als Grundlagenprojekt gesehen
und weniger als eine Einrichtung, die angewandte Forschung betreibt.
Erst später hat man dann vielleicht erkannt, dass diese Grundlagenforschung
sehr viel produziert und entwickelt, was man im angewandten Bereich braucht.
Beschleunigertechnologie, auch die Detektoren, die wir entwickeln,
ist der zweite große Bereich am CERN, wird vielfach in der Medizin verwendet.
Computing, World Wide Web brauche ich glaube ich nicht extra erwähnen,
aber die ursprünglichen Ziele und nach wie vor die Ziele des CERN sind absolute
Grundlagenforschung, für die es unmittelbar keine Anwendung gibt.
Vielleicht darf man auch nicht vergessen, denke ich zumindest, dass am Beginn des CERN,
die Maschinen, die wir jetzt besprochen haben, vielleicht bis hin zum SBS,
der dann immerhin schon sieben Kilometer war, keine so riesigen,
gigantischen Projekte sind, wie wir sie jetzt vielleicht sehen.
Das hat sich ja alles mit der Zeit entwickelt. Das waren ja am Beginn kleine
Gruppen, wenige Leute, die Experimente gemacht haben.
Erst mit der Zeit, als die Beschleunigung immer größer wurden,
die Experimente immer komplexer, die Fragestellungen immer komplexer,
hat sich das hin zu Kollaborationen entwickelt, die jetzt aus 3000 Wissenschaftlern bestehen.
Eine Entwicklung, die übrigens nicht nur in der Teilchenphysik stattgefunden
hat, sondern auch in anderen Bereichen der Wissenschaft.
Kommen wir vielleicht noch mal zu diesen Meilensteinen, um daran auch vielleicht
so ein bisschen die Entwicklung auch festmachen zu können. Also wenn ich das
richtig sehe, diese neutralen Ströme, das war so 73, so größenordnungsmäßig.
Aber diese W&Z-Busse waren 1983.
Dazu musste, das ist vielleicht interessant zu erklären, dazu musste der SPS
umgebaut werden. Der SPS wurde gebaut als eine Maschine für Fixed-Target-Experimente,
ich habe das schon erklärt.
Beschleunigt die Protonen und schießt sie dann auf einen Materioblocker und
macht dann die Messungen. Aber da geht sehr viel Energie verloren.
Wenn das Proton auf einen Block trifft, geht viel der Energie hinten wieder raus.
Viel effizienter wäre es, wenn man Protonen frontal qualitieren lässt.
Da hat der Karl Rubia, weil man sozusagen doppelte Geschwindigkeit hat,
mehr sogar frontal volle Energie bei der involvierten Teilchen,
steht dann zur Verfügung.
Und da hatte der Karl Rubia, später der Nobelpreisträger, die Idee gehabt, wir bauen das SPS um.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt gelang es bereits am CERN Antiprotonen zu erzeugen.
Das sind die Antiteilchen der Protonen. Ein Proton besteht aus drei Quarks,
ein Antiproton aus drei Antiquarks, hat aber sonst gleiche Eigenschaften außer
entgegengesetzte Ladung.
Und er hat jetzt die Idee gehabt, man kann eigentlich in dem gleichen Ring,
im Uhrzeigersinn die Protonen, gegen den Uhrzeigersinn die Antiprotonen.
Wenn man sich überlegt, wie die Felder der Magnete wirken, wirken sie genau
entgegengesetzter, aber auch entgegengesetzter Ladung.
Aber man nutzt sozusagen die Technik doppelt.
Man nutzt die Technik des gleichen Beschleuniger, die gleiche Vakuumröhre,
die gleichen Kavitäten, Hohlraumresonatoren und beschleunigt in die eine Richtung
Protonen, in die andere Richtung Antiprotonen und kann sie dann zu einem Frontalcrash
in der Mitte eines Detektors zusammenführen.
Aber wo kriegt man denn so Antiprotonen her? Gibt es ja so Regale, wo die so drin stehen?
Mittlerweile schon.
Ach wirklich?
Antiprotonen entstehen auch bei hochenergetischen Reaktionen.
Wenn Sie einen Proton nehmen, wenn die Energie groß genug ist und Sie siehst,
dass Sie auf ein Plei-Target kommen hinten alle möglichen Teilchen heraus.
Unter anderem auch Antiprotone.
Sehr selten. Aber wenn man eine gute Apparatur aufbaut, kann man diese Antiprotonen
vom Rest der Teilchen separieren.
Und mittlerweile wissen wir auch, wie wir sie aufheben können.
Also wir haben mittlerweile Regale, magnetische Fallen, wo wir Antiprotonen speichern.
Vielleicht kommen wir zu dem später zurück. Das ist ein ganz spannendes Thema.
Aber bleiben wir bei dem SPS.
Der SPS wurde umgebaut. Zwei Experimente wurden gebaut, UR1 und UR2.
Ich hatte das Vergnügen, als kleiner Student beim Experiment UR1 mitarbeiten zu können.
Und durch diesen Frontal-Crash der Protonen und der Antiprotonen stand genug
Energie zur Verfügung, um die W- und Z-Bosonen zu erzeugen. Und so gelang der
Nachweis der W- und Z-Bosonen.
Das war sicher das größte, bis zur Entdeckung des Higgs, das größte Erfolg am
Zehren, der Nachweis der W- und Z-Bosonen.
1983, ein Jahr später, hat der Karl Rubia gemeinsam mit dem Simon van der Meer,
einem Beschleunigerexperten, den Nobelpreis bekommen.
Das Simon van der Meer, dem ist es gelungen die Maschine so umzubauen,
dass die Antiprotonen auch fokussiert bleiben und in der Maschine bleiben.
Das war technologisch ein sehr wichtiger Fortschritt um diese Maschine überhaupt zu realisieren.
Und 1983 gab es dann auch noch kein Internet, aber dann hat sich auch die Medienwelt
schon so ein bisschen verändert.
Das dürfte dann schon ein bisschen mehr Impact gehabt haben oder dauerte das
immer noch Monate lang bis das alles zur Kenntnis genommen hat?
Ich hab damals schon Physik studiert, das war knapp bevor ich das erste Mal an den Zehren kam.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass es im ORF I vorgekommen ist.
Ja gut, alles klar.
Als Physiker hat man das natürlich mitbekommen, überhaupt wenn man schon ein
Teilchen Physik studiert.
Wie ging es dann weiter?
Ja, jetzt, wir haben ja gesprochen über die Personen, elektroschwache Wechselwirkung.
Gibt es drei Personen, Photon, W und Z Person.
Und der große Unterschied ist zwischen diesen Personen der riesige Masseunterschied.
Die Photonen sind masselos, deswegen fliegen sie auch mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit
und ähnlicher Reichweite.
Die W- und Z-Personen haben zwischen 80 und 90 Gigaelektronenvolt Masse.
Das entspricht der 80 bis 90 fachen Protonenmasse.
Also das sind riesige, schwere Auslausteilchen.
Und das passt nicht ganz zusammen. Da fehlt etwas in der Theorie.
Und da haben viele Theoretiker damals nachgedacht, wie kann das,
oder die Überlegung fand schon in den 60er Jahren statt, Wie kann man diese
ungroßen Massenunterschiede erklären?
Und da kommen wir jetzt schon langsam zum Higgs, zum Higgs-Feld.
Einige Theoretiker, allen voran die Theoretiker Braut,
Angler und Higgs, haben dann eine Theorie aufgestellt, dass es im Universum
ein Feld geben muss, das für diese Massenunterschiede verantwortlich ist.
Wir nennen es jetzt das Braut-Angler-Higgs-Feld.
Und der Higgs war der Theoretiker, der erkannt hat, dass wenn es ein solches
Feld gibt, dann muss es auch ein Teilchen dazu geben, das Feldteilchen.
Und deswegen nennen wir das Higgs-Boson jetzt Higgs-Boson.
Da müssen wir vielleicht nochmal einen kleinen Physik-Exkurs einwerfen und so
ein bisschen auf diese Idee dieser Felder kommen.
Das ist ja eine komplexe Materie.
Das Verständnis, was ich so ein bisschen für mich erlangt habe oder glaube erlangt zu haben,
Also ich rede quasi von dieser Quantenfeldtheorie, also die Annahme,
dass eigentlich für jedes Teilchen, korrigieren sie mich, werden sie wahrscheinlich
gleich tun, mehr oder weniger eigentlich auch ein passendes Feld dazu existiert.
Wir eigentlich quasi dadurch in der Vorstellung von einer permanenten,
wabernden Masse unterschiedlicher Feldtypen umgeben sind und diese ganzen Teilchen,
die wir dann sozusagen finden, sind dann so mehr oder weniger Zuspitzungen in diesem Feld.
Kulminationen, die dann sozusagen greifbar, quantisierbar,
also zählbar werden, die diskret abgeteilt sind,
die sozusagen so viel aus diesem Feld herausragen, dass man sagen kann,
da ist ein sichtbares, greifbares, zählbares Element aus diesem Feld.
Ist das ein Bild, was passt?
Ja, ich würde das Einzige, was ich korrigieren würde, wir sind nicht von den
Feldern umgeben, sondern durchdrungen von all diesen Feldern.
Und ja, die Teilchen, wenn sie sozusagen an dem Feld rütteln, entstehen.
Die Teilchen, genau. Weil das Bild hat mir ehrlich gesagt sehr geholfen dabei,
weil so dieses, diese ganze Welt aus so herumfliegenden Objekten sich zusammenzubauen,
macht's auch irgendwie schwierig, weil einfach alles permanent irgendwie kollidiert
und wie ein riesiger Billardtisch funktionieren würde.
Aber sozusagen alles so ein bisschen als wabernde Masse zu verstehen,
wo sich dann irgendwie immer wieder was konkretisiert,
das passt ja dann auch irgendwie gut so mit diesen Beschreibungen zusammen in der Quantentheorie,
dass ja alles ja Welle und Teilchen gleichzeitig ist,
dieser Dualismus, dieses Dinge sind nicht so konkret greifbar,
ich kann sagen mit welcher Wahrscheinlichkeit irgendwas irgendwo ist,
aber nichts ist wirklich total bestimmt.
Was ja sagen wir mal auch die einfache Physik am Anfang des 20.
Jahrhunderts auch so ein bisschen in Wallung gebracht hat, wo ja auch viele,
ich glaube auch Einstein, so ein bisschen ihre Zweifel hatten,
dass das sozusagen so ein Bild sein kann, mit dem sich alles erklären lässt,
weil man eigentlich ja bis dahin immer so ein bisschen Konkretes haben wollte,
Festgelegtes haben wollte, Abzählbares haben wollte und das ja sagen wir mal
Blick aufs große auch irgendwie gepasst hat.
Allgemeine Relativitätstheorie war in der Lage so das Weltall zu beschreiben
und auf einmal passte die Bewegung der Planeten und es ging irgendwie alles
wunderbar auf und diesen großen Dimensionen,
ja konnte man das alles so nachvollziehen, aber umso mehr man ins Kleine schaute,
umso waberiger und unbestimmter wurde irgendwie alles und das dann irgendwie
zusammenzubringen ist ja im Prinzip auch immer noch so ein bisschen die Aufgabe.
Also diese Felder spielen einfach eine große Rolle und das Higgs-Boson,
um da jetzt drauf zu kommen, oder die Higgs-Entdeckung, oder sagen wir überhaupt
erstmal die Theorie vom Higgs, ist ja sozusagen der Ansatz.
Okay, wie, was ist überhaupt Masse? Und damit in letzter Linie auch so die Frage,
was ist überhaupt Energie, wenn das sozusagen das gleiche ist,
was ist das für eine Eigenschaft und wovon eigentlich?
Und diese Theorie, wann wurde die aufgestellt?
Ende der 60er Jahre.
Das muss ja ein unglaublich weitblickendes Gedankenmodell gewesen sein,
was jetzt sozusagen gesagt hat, okay unter all diesen Feldern,
die wir sowieso haben, gibt's dann nochmal eins.
Das sehen wir nicht, aber nehmen wir einfach mal an, das ist irgendwie da und
es ist in gewisser Hinsicht so ein Metafeld, was für alle auch nochmal eine
Eigenschaft hinzufügt.
Also vereinigen sich dann letzten Endes alle Felder.
Ja, es war sicher damals eine sehr mutige Vorhersage, ein solches zusätzliches Feld einzuführen.
Aber mathematisch in ihrem Mechanismus, diesem Brauteiger-Higgs-Mechanismus, hat das gepasst.
Und hat all das erklärt, was man damals gemessen hat. Was man sich erklären
konnte. Genau. Und seit diesen 60er Jahren suchen wir dieses Higgs-Teilchen.
Weil, was die Theorie nicht vorhergesagt hat, bei welcher Masse sich dieses
Teilchen befinden sollte.
Deswegen haben dann eigentlich Generationen von Physikern versucht,
dieses Higgs-Teilchen nachzuweisen.
Man hat aber erst einen LHC gebraucht, um genug Energie in diese Kollisionen
zu bringen, damit dieses Higgs-Teilchen entsteht.
Und zweitens entsteht dieses Higgs-Teilchen, weil es auch so schwer ist,
sehr, sehr selten. Das heißt, man braucht auch noch einen Beschleuniger,
der eine hohe Interaktionsrate, eine hohe Intensität hat.
Und das war erst durch den LHC möglich.
Okay wir lassen nochmal kurz auf Dröseln.
Also die Voraussage war ja im Prinzip es gibt nochmal ein Feld und nennen wir
es jetzt mal das Higgs Feld und das hat eine bestimmte Eigenschaft und um es
nachweisen zu können muss man sozusagen ein Teilchen finden,
also so eine Kulmination in diesem Feld, die erst dadurch angeregt wird,
wenn man extrem hohe Energien zusammenbringt.
Was heißt das jetzt mit ich suche ein Teilchen in einem bestimmten Energiebereich?
Also wie muss man sich das jetzt… Ja bis jetzt haben wir eigentlich nur über
den Beschleuniger gesprochen.
Der Beschleuniger ist nur eine Komponente. Wie ich schon gesagt habe,
um nachweislich das Higgs Teilchen brauche ich einen Beschleuniger,
Der bei der Kollision, beim LHC, beschleunigen wir Protonen in beide Richtungen.
Es kommt zur Kollision zwischen den einzelnen Quarks in den Protonen,
beziehungsweise die Gluonen, die die Protonen zusammenhalten.
Und bei dieser Kollision muss genug Energie zur Verfügung stehen,
damit die Masse des Higgs überhaupt entstehen kann.
Zweitens braucht man diese hohe Intensität, damit es auch oft genug entsteht.
Aber das ist nur der erste Teil. Jetzt hat man es erst einmal erzeugt.
Dann muss es nachgewiesen werden. Das Higgs-Boson zerfällt instantan.
Man sieht es, man kann es auch im Detektor nicht nachweisen.
Was man nachweisen kann, sind die Zerfallsprodukte.
Da entstehen aber alle Teilchen, die wir bis jetzt kennen.
Der LHC hat eine so hohe Energie, dass er die ganzen Teilchen so erzeugen kann.
In einer einzigen Kollision?
In einer einzigen Kollision. Wir haben aber jetzt eine Milliarde Kollisionen
pro Sekunde, rund um die Uhr, fast das ganze Jahr.
Das heißt, die Detektoren, die Experimente müssen so aufgebaut sein,
dass sie zum einen die Kollisionen auseinander dividieren können,
messen können, was dabei entstanden ist, und dann vergleichen wir in der Analyse
mit dem, was wir erwarten.
Wir vergleichen zum Beispiel die Verteilung gewisser Teilchen mit einem Modell
ohne Higgs und mit einem Modell mit Higgs.
Und dann schauen wir, was besser passt.
Detail ist natürlich komplizierter. Zum einen machen wir eine blinde Analyse,
damit wir das Ergebnis nicht, wir wollen ein Higgs finden und dann drehen wir
so lange an den Parametern der Analyse, bis wir das wirklich finden.
Also diese Analyse, was ich gerade gesagt habe, die wird blind gemacht.
Das heißt, der Bereich, den man untersucht, der wird nie gezeigt auf dem Platz.
Man definiert die Analyse, das sind ganze Teams von hunderten Leuten, die daran arbeiten.
Man definiert die Suche, man definiert die Simulation, die Vergleiche und wenn man dann sicher ist,
dass alles passen muss, dann öffnet man sozusagen die Box und schaut nach,
ob das, was man sieht, der Theorie mit Higgs oder ohne Higgs entspricht.
Und dann sieht man, dann hat man vielleicht dann die Zuhörer ja damals diese Plots 2012 gesehen,
Da sieht man eine Verteilung, die hat eine kontinuierliche Kurve und irgendwo
plötzlich steht ein Peak heraus.
Und da haben wir dann das X-Boson identifiziert.
Das heißt man hat genug Experimente gefahren mit unterschiedlichen Energien
und in diesem einen spezifischen Energiebereich waren dann die Explosionen der Art,
dass sich eben der komplette Teilchenzoo dort entwickelt hat und in der Verteilung,
was da, in welcher Reihenfolge und wie viel sich sozusagen herausgetan hat,
entsprach der Vorhersage des Higgs-Feldes und des Higgs-Teilchens und das hat
man so in diesen ganzen anderen Energiebereichen nicht gesehen.
Was war nochmal kurz diese Energie genau? 125 GV. 125 Gigaelektronenvolt.
Das entspricht der Masse von 125 Protonen.
Ruhemasse von 125 Protonen.
Klingt nicht viel, wenn das so rot und so rumliegt.
Aber wie kann man sich das...
Entspricht glaube ich nicht, weil das ein Xenonatom war.
Ja aber wie kann man sich vorstellen, dass es sich dabei um viel Energie handelt,
wenn die auch einfach so rumliegen können.
Naja herumliegen, wie ich ja gesagt habe, das Higgs Boson entsteht und zerfällt sofort.
Ja, aber nur diese Energie. Wie kriegt man ein Gefühl dafür,
dass das viel Energie ist? Weil es ist ja viel Energie, wenn man es so groß nennt.
Also zumindest meine persönliche Normierung ist die Energie,
also die Masse eines Protons oder Neutrons, das ist ungefähr ein GeV.
Das ist sozusagen meine Kalibrationseinheit.
Alles was drüber ist, ist schwer, alles was darunter ist, ist leicht.
Klingt aber nicht beeindruckend.
Nein und ist auch nicht wissenschaftlich, um ehrlich zu sein.
Okay, aber nehmen wir einfach mal hin. Es ist eine Menge Holz und das überhaupt
erstmal in einem Beschleunigerring zu erzeugen braucht eben all diese ganze
Technologie und wir werden hier über den LHC in anderen Folgen noch sehr viel
detaillierter sprechen.
So und dann entstand das,
ich meine das ist ja jetzt nicht so, man schaut auf den Bildschirm und macht so pling,
sondern wir haben es ja schon gesagt, über einen langen Zeitraum permanent wird
immer wieder quasi dieses Experiment permanent durchgeführt oder es wird einfach die ganze Zeit,
werden einfach Daten erfasst und dann zusammengesammelt, Über welchen Zeitraum
musste man dann sozusagen schauen, um letzten Endes dieses Bild und auch die
Gewissheit zu bekommen.
Weil es ist ja nicht ein Ereignis, sondern es ist ja sozusagen ein Ereignis,
was mit einer bestimmten Wahrscheinlichkeit auftrifft.
Der Nachweis gelang relativ rasch. Mit den Daten von ungefähr einem Jahr hatte man die Gewissheit,
dass die Abweichung von der Theorie ohne Higgs deutlich genug ist,
dass man eindeutig sagen kann, da ist etwas Neues passiert.
Das hat ungefähr die Eigenschaft eines Higgs-Posons und für die Entdeckung hat das ausgereicht.
Aber jetzt, was wir seitdem machen, seit zehn Jahren, ist, genauer zu studieren dieses Teilchen.
Und zwar auf der einen Seite die Reaktionen, die zur Erzeugung eines Higgs-Bosons führen.
Darum gibt es eine ganze Reihe. Und dann auch die Zerfallsmechanismen.
Das Higgs-Boson kann in alle bekannten Teilchen mit Masse zerfallen.
Das ist ja sozusagen die Essenz des Higgs-Bosons, es koppelt an alle Teilchen mit Masse.
Das heißt, in erster Linie zerfällt es in Teilchen mit großer Masse,
dann mit geringer Statistik in kleinere und so weiter. Und das untersuchen wir jetzt.
Und dazu brauchen wir viele dieser Experimente.
Jede Kollision ist sozusagen ein Experiment, bei der eine dieser Reaktionen abläuft.
In den seltensten Fällen entsteht ein Higgs-Boson. Es entstehen natürlich alle
anderen Teilchen, wie ich schon gesagt habe.
Man darf auch nicht glauben, dass wir am LHC nur das Higgs-Boson untersuchen.
Die großen Experimente machen, wenn ich jetzt grob schätze, dürfte an die 100
verschiedene Analysen gleichzeitig, wovon nur wenige das Higgs-Boson betreffen.
Es gibt dann Analysen, um detailliert andere Teilchen des Standardmodells zu
untersuchen, wo erst jetzt die Energie zur Verfügung steht.
Es gibt viele Suchen nach zusätzlichen neuen Teilchen oder Feldern.
Also es ist eine riesen Bandbreite. Es arbeiten ja nicht umsonst mehrere tausend
Physiker pro Experiment.
Und viele hunderte, auch mehrere tausende in Summe, an all den vier LHC-Experimenten.
Studenten machen ihre Dissertation. Die arbeiten nicht alle an den Higgs-Boson.
Aber natürlich, nachdem der LHC die einzige Maschine ist, die Higgs-Bosonen
produzieren kann, ist das natürlich ein Gebiet, das wir mit hoher Priorität untersuchen.
2012 gab's Internet und ich erinnere mich noch relativ gut wie es so langsam anfing raus zu sickern,
dass wohl irgendwie was passiert ist, also ich weiß gar nicht ganz genau,
ich glaube es ist dann erstmal angekündigt worden, dass es eine Pressekonferenz
geben wird, da waren dann schon die Hände nass bei vielen und es sickerte halt
durch, weil es war ja auch klar wonach gesucht wurde.
Und es ist auch klar, dass jetzt nicht für jede Minimalerkenntnis gleich eine
Presskonferenz aufgesetzt wird und insbesondere wenn dann so eine Geheimniskreberei
auch noch drumherum gemacht wird, was es denn ist, da waren dann schon alle irgendwie nervös.
Und das war, und das ist jetzt so ein bisschen meine Außenperspektive,
da hatte man wirklich so den Eindruck so, oh wow, okay, gut,
jetzt kommt hier irgendwie das Zern und macht einen bold move.
Also das war wirklich spürbar, dass das jetzt mal etwas ist,
auch wenn das irgendwie so ein sonderbarer Moment war,
dass man dann auf dieser Veranstaltung Wissenschaftler gesehen hat und dann
wurde so eine, mehr oder weniger langweilig aussehende Kurve auf den Beamer
geworfen und alle sind ausgeflippt, als hätten sie jetzt gerade irgendwie Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft zu feiern.
Ja, und der Grund ist diese Blind Analysis, von der ich vorher gesprochen habe.
Ein, zwei Wochen vorher wussten selbst wir nicht, dass wir wirklich schon bei
dieser Entdeckung sind.
Weil es gab die beiden Experimente, Atlas und CMS, die mit unterschiedlichen
Experimenten, unterschiedlichen Detektoren, unterschiedlicher Software,
unterschiedlichen Personen ihre Daten analysieren.
Damit ist sichergestellt, dass die Ergebnisse völlig unabhängig sind.
Diese Gruppen reden auch nicht miteinander.
Es gibt sogar Geschichten, dass Ehepaare, die eine arbeitete in Atlas,
die andere in CMS, die sind heimlich aufs WC gegangen, um zu telefonieren mit
ihren Kollegen, als es um die Analyse ging.
Und dann kommt es zu diesem Unplugging und dann sehen die Kollaborationen zum
ersten Mal, ob sie wirklich was gefunden haben und wie groß die Abweichung ist.
Wir müssen ja auch sicherstellen, dass das eindeutig ist. Das peinlichste wäre,
der CERN verkündet das X-Poson und ein Jahr später müssen wir sagen,
es war doch nur eine statistische Fluktuation.
Und da gibt es diese sogenannte 5-Sigma-Grenze in der Teilchenphysik,
ab der man von einer Entdeckung spricht.
Da ist dann mit sehr hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit ausgeschlossen,
dass das eine Wahrscheinlichkeit verteilt.
Und das heißt, kurz vor der Pressekonferenz wussten erst die Kollaborationen,
dass sie etwas haben, aber sie wussten nicht, ob sie beide das gleiche sehen.
Das wusste nur ein paar Tage vorher der CERN-Generaldirektor.
Der wurde von beiden Kollaborationen informiert und der sah,
dass sich diese Entdeckungen entdeckten.
Denn es hätte ja sein können, ATLAS findet etwas bei 100 GeV,
CMS findet etwas bei 200 GeV und dann glaubt keiner was.
Und in dieser Pressekonferenz, Also in dem Seminar, das der Pressekonferenz
vorangegangen ist, haben zum ersten Mal die Spokesbörsen bei der Kollaboration
ihre Ergebnisse gezeigt.
Sprühen wir nochmal ein paar Wochen zurück oder wie weit auch immer.
Also die Experimente, ich meine, ich habe ja mein Verständnis so,
LHC arbeitet jetzt sozusagen permanent Es gibt solche Kampagnen über einen längeren
Zeitraum bis dann mal wieder eine technische Pause durchgeführt wird.
Also es gab ja einen Upgrade von dem großen Beschleunigerring,
dem Large Hadron Collider im Vorfeld, ich weiß nicht wie viele Jahre vorher
war das, der letzte Ausbau, der sozusagen diese Energien ermöglicht hat?
In der ersten Stufe war das eigentlich, sogar mit einer halben Energie ist der
LHC zu dem Zeitpunkt gelaufen. Mh.
Die echte Experimentierphase hat 2010 begonnen, sehr geringe Intensität,
das war erst der Start und dann 2011, Beginn 2012 ist dann die Intensität immer
höher gesteigert worden und damit war dann genug Statistik da um ein paar hundert
dieser Higgs Ereignisse herauszufiltern.
Okay aber das läuft ja dann sozusagen Tag und Nacht und wird die ganze Zeit
aufgezeichnet und die Daten werden abgespeichert und da fließt ja auch irgendwie,
da werden sehr viele Festplatten gefüllt und man kann ja die Daten gar nicht
in Echtzeit so analysieren nehm ich mal an,
also das ist ja sozusagen etwas, da muss ja quasi parallel muss man die ganze
Zeit auf diesen Daten arbeiten und man ist den Experimenten immer Wochen,
vielleicht Monate hinterher, weiß ich nicht genau.
Und sowohl bei dem einen Experiment als auch bei dem anderen,
Atlas und CMS, wurde auf die selben Zahlen reingeschaut und das Ziel war schon,
okay Higgs, also nicht nur aber eben auch und die Gruppen die sich darum gekümmert haben,
haben halt einfach ihre Daten analysiert so und Gab's dann irgendwie so einen
Stichtag, wo du gesagt hast, okay, jetzt schauen wir uns mal alles an und werten
das aus und das haben dann beide Gruppen parallel gemacht und das wussten die
aber auch, dass sie das beide parallel machen.
Ja solche Schnittpunkte ergeben sich automatisch zum Beispiel Ende des Jahres,
wo der Beschleuniger dann für ein paar Monate abgedreht wird,
dann nimmt man die Daten des letzten Jahres als Paket, analysiert das und zeigt dann die Ergebnisse.
Okay, das heißt das war dann Ende 2011?
In dem Fall war der Zeitpunkt, wo man den Schnitt gemacht hat,
Anfang 2012. Also ich bin jetzt nicht sicher, Mai oder so. Bis zu dem Zeitpunkt
hat man die Daten genommen.
Dann hat man parallel schon die ganze Analyse vorbereitet. Dann hat man noch
ein paar Wochen Zeit gehabt, um abzuschließen.
Und dann rechtzeitig, das Timing wird vorgegeben durch die Konferenzen.
Wir haben üblicherweise eine Serie von Sommerkonferenzen und Winterkonferenzen.
Und da versuchen die Experimente ihre Ergebnisse, ihre neuen Ergebnisse zu zeigen.
Und in diesem Fall 2012 war es eine internationale Konferenz in Melbourne,
bei der das Ergebnis gezeigt werden sollte.
Eine Sommerkonferenz.
Eine Sommerkonferenz, genau.
Wobei in Melbourne ist ja dann wieder Winter.
Das war relativ kühl dort.
Und am ersten Tag dieser Konferenz wurde sozusagen das Ergebnis verkündet.
Ok, aber wie ist das dann sozusagen abgelaufen? Das heißt beide Gruppen haben
dann sozusagen auf ihre Daten geschaut und dann dürfte so beiden so ein bisschen
der Mund trocken geworden sein.
Weil ich meine, hat man damit gerechnet, dass man dann schon am Ziel ist?
Also war das sozusagen die Erwartungshaltung, jetzt haben wir eigentlich die
Energie, jetzt muss es passen.
Sowas kann man ja eigentlich gar nicht sicher, da kann man sich nicht sicher sein.
Man konnte sich nicht sicher sein, weil es war ja nur eine Theorie.
Es hätte gar nichts auch herauskommen können.
Also man konnte sich nicht sicher sein. Es gab natürlich schon in der Analyse,
vielleicht ein Jahr vorher, gab es Fluktuationen, aber Fluktuationen kommen und gehen.
Also wo man in diesem Bereich was gesehen hat, aber eben nicht diese 5 Sigma, sondern nur 2, 3 Sigma.
Das ist eine Wahrscheinlichkeit, die kann mit ein bisschen mehr Statistik wieder verschwinden.
Also die Optimisten haben natürlich schon geglaubt, das kann was werden,
aber eigentlich viele, ich persönlich war auch überrascht, dass man so rasch
zu diesem 5 Sigma Schwelle gekommen ist.
Und zwar beide Experimente.
Beide Experimente und sehr genau übereinstimmend.
Also da war ein geringer Fehler zwischen den beiden Experimenten.
Okay und jetzt nochmal diese Timeline bis zu der Veröffentlichung.
Also zwei Wochen vorher waren dann sozusagen alle mit ihren Daten durch und
haben dann Kurve gesehen und jede Gruppe selber meinte, okay wir sehen das.
Aber die beide wussten nichts voneinander.
Beide wussten nicht was sie sehen und ob sie was gesehen haben und schon gar nicht wo.
Ok und dann fand dieses Seminar statt, was dann eine Woche vorher vor der Veröffentlichung war?
Nein, es war am Tag der Konferenz, am ersten Tag der Konferenz.
Die Präsentation beider Experimente wurde von hier übertragen nach Melbourne.
Und da haben dann überhaupt das erste Mal festgestellt, dass das so ist.
Dass beide etwas sehen und es übereinstimmt und das war dann eigentlich wirklich…
Aber das war dann auch noch nicht öffentlich.
Gleich darauf gab's die Pressekonferenz, so weit ich mich erinnere,
das ist auch mehr als 10 Jahre her.
Ich meine es gab so ein bisschen Vorlauf.
Ja, Gerüchte, Gerüchte, jeder Kollaboration bestand aus ca. 3000 Leuten.
Da entstehen Gerüchte.
Ich meinte ja schon, es sickerte halt was durch. Aber ok, jetzt verstehe ich das erst.
Es war dann wirklich auf dieser Konferenz eine sehr sehr sehr frische finale Erkenntnis,
die eigentlich erst einen Tag vorher so gewonnen wurde und die dann,
ja, die dann jetzt wirklich aber auch mal international auch wirklich abgestrahlt
hat, also das war dann schon auch wirklich mal ein echter Eureka Moment.
Gigantische Resonanz hervorgerufen, die uns Physiker alle überrascht und ich
würde fast sagen überfahren hat.
Warum?
Weil wir mit einem solchen Medieninteresse alle nicht gerechnet haben.
Also ich kann mich erinnern, ich war damals im Institut für Ironie-Physik,
habe Interviews gegeben und die Fernsehstationen und Radiostationen haben sich
am Gang geprügelt um die Plätze.
Und so ein Interesse als Teilchenphysiker hat man in seinem Leben sehr selten.
Im Nachgang gab es dann eine gute Erklärung dafür, was das sozusagen bewirkt hat.
Hatte das was mit dem CERN zu tun? Hatte das was mit dem Thema zu tun?
Also was hat das sozusagen gemacht, dass das so eine Aufmerksamkeit erzeugt
hat? Weil das ist ja ein Prozess, der muss ja auch an so einem medialen Apparat
sich erstmal aus irgendetwas heraus entwickeln, also was war die Grundlage für dieses Interesse?
Ich meine man hätte ja auch sagen können, ja Wissenschaftler haben ja irgendwas
rausgefunden, denen interessiert das schon.
Sicher hat der CERN eine Rolle gespielt. Der Status des CERN,
dann die Tatsache, dass der LHC doch eine sehr riesige Maschine ist,
die von der Technologie her sehr aufregend ist, wo man auch sehr schöne Bilder
zeigen kann, nicht nur von der Installation, aber auch diese Kollisionen, die bunten Bilder.
Ich meine mich, jetzt fällt es mir gerade wieder ein, da gab es doch vorher
so eine putzige Diskussion um das Erzeugen von schwarzen Löchern.
Vorher im Betriebnahme des LHC gab es ja die Befürchtung und da gab es einige Esoteriker,
die das bis zum Karlsruher Verwaltungsgerichtshof gebraucht haben,
die Gefahr, dass der LHC schwarze Löcher erzeugen kann und dieses schwarze Loch die Erde verschlingt.
Das hat sicher auch das Interesse.
Und konnte es?
Nein.
Warum?
Es gibt die Erklärung der Theoretiker. Da hätte ich auch meine Bedenken.
Theoretiker haben sie auch schon geirrt.
Aber ich gebe ihnen die Erklärung des Experimentalphysikers.
Jede Sekunde finden viele LHCs in der Atmosphäre statt.
Weil die Protonen, die aus der kosmischen Strahlen haben zum Teil eine viel
höhere Energie als der LHC jemals erzeugen kann.
Würden solche Kollisionen schwarze Löcher erzeugen, gäbe es uns nicht mehr.
Ende der Diskussion. Im Endeffekt wurde es mal gerichtlich festgestellt,
dass es keine Gefahr gibt.
Ja, aber das kann wirklich der Katalysator gewesen sein, da kann man in der
Ethik wirklich glücklicherweise sein.
Unglücklicherweise kam es ja nach der ersten Inbetriebnahme des LHCs zu einem Unfall.
Es ist ja eine superleitende Leitung, hat einen Fehler entwickelt und dadurch
ist der LHC beschädigt worden 2008.
Das hat bereits ein großes Medieninteresse hervorgerufen.
Riesenmaschine, viel Geld und ist nach zwei Wochen schon kaputt.
Ja, stimmt.
Das hat sicher auch das Interesse und vielleicht hat das in Summe alles zusammen
zu einer Steigerung geführtes Dannen.
Am 4. Juli 2012 zu dieser Medien Explosion geführt hat.
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen, man ist ja auch immer so ein Thema in der Wissenschaft,
wie kriegt man denn eigentlich auch so die Begeisterung für das Thema mit.
Ich merk das ja so ein bisschen als Beobachter von außen,
der ich jetzt viel mit Wissenschaftlern aller Couleur spreche,
insbesondere halt in der Raumfahrt und wenn man erstmal so spürt wie viel Begeisterung
für das Thema dort einfach ist, wie besessen eigentlich alle davon sind,
weil in dem Moment wo man sich das halt wirklich mal genauer anschaut auch klar
wird, was das Faszinosum ausmacht.
Verständnis des Weltalls, der unglaublichen Weite, die Komplexität in unserer
Entstehungsgeschichte und des Seins,
dass das ja sozusagen, dass dieser Arbeit ja der Schlüssel zu dieser Erkenntnis
ist und dass diese Erkenntnis an sich irgendwie einfach eine große Bedeutung hat,
weil das ja im Prinzip auch so ein bisschen, sagen wir mal der Plump gesagt,
so ein bisschen Sinn und Erläuterung des Lebens und des Seins ist.
Andere Leute suchen die Erleuchtung, indem sie meditierend im Wald sitzen und
andere versuchen es halt irgendwie Erkenntnisse über Experimente und Theorien
zu finden und das ist ja sozusagen das was begeistert,
aber nach außen, nachdem eben die erste Hälfte des 20.
Jahrhunderts irgendwie diese Begeisterung auch überall hatte, Ich
kann mich noch erinnern, wenn man sich so, Reden von Politikern,
was hab ich da mal gesehen, Mitterrand, auch so in der Zeit noch, wie, mit wieviel...
Anerkennung und Bewunderung wie für diesen wissenschaftlichen Fortschritt auch
in der öffentlichen politischen Diskussion mit der Öffentlichkeit gearbeitet wurde.
Das hat dann halt einfach später stark nachgelassen und interessante Geschichten
zu erzählen ist heute so ein bisschen glaube ich der Weg und das hier waren
es in gewisser Hinsicht so die Unfälle,
so dieses irgendwie ja schwarzes Loch die Erde wird verschlungen hö hö hö So
hat sich halt einfach gut gemacht und Unfälle kommen ja sowieso immer gut und ich glaube,
dass Europa generell auch immer so eine gewisse Kommunikationsschwäche hat,
man sieht das ja auch bei der ESA, die im Vergleich zu den Geschichtenerzählern
der NASA, die das einfach immer schön dramatisieren können.
Ich sag nur so sieben Minuten des Terrors bei einer Marslandung und so weiter.
Einfach ein hervorragendes Framing einer wissenschaftlichen Geschichte.
Insofern hat das dazu beigetragen. Aber ich denke, dass jetzt schon das CERN
einfach auch so einen gewissen Kultstatus dadurch jetzt auch erreicht hat und
da war dann diese Higgs Geschichte irgendwie, passt da dann irgendwie auf einmal alles zusammen.
So die Suche nach der Erkenntnis, 50 Jahre Wahnzündung glaube ich,
seit der Theorie oder so, bis man das dann auch wirklich gefunden hat,
das ist natürlich dann auch so ein schöner Rundenschluss gewesen.
Dann die unglückliche Bezeichnung Gottesteilchen zu Wirks,
natürlich für einen Physiker ein Albtraum ist diese Bezeichnung,
aber praktisch in jeder Zeitung, in jedem Medium vorgekommen ist,
das hat natürlich dem auch noch einen Auftritt gegeben.
Aber das ist vielleicht ganz gut, greifen wir das doch nochmal auf, Gotteszeichen.
Was da im Prinzip so ein bisschen dahinter steht ist, dass sozusagen das Higgs-Boson
und das Higgs-Feld und der Nachweis dessen im Prinzip auch so ein bisschen den
Schluss um das Standardmodell der Elementarteilchen dargestellt hat.
Den Schlussstein oder den Beginn von neuen Erkenntnissen,
denn das Higgs-Feld und das Higgs-Teilchen ist nicht ein beliebiges weiteres Teilchen oder Feld,
von dem wir sehr viele kennen, sondern das Higgs-Feld und Teilchen hat ganz
spezielle Eigenschaften, nämlich fast keine.
Es hat keine Ladung, keine Richtung. Es ist das einfachste Objekt,
das man sich vorstellen kann.
Es ist nur ein Feld, das das ganze Universum durchdringt.
Aber das tun ja alle Felder.
Aber mit Richtungen. Mit Richtungen, wie zum Beispiel elektromagnetische Felder,
die haben alle Meereigenschaften, Meereparameter.
Das X-Feld hat… Das ist einfach nur da.
Ja, auch das Higgs-Boson, es hat nur Masse. Es hat keine Spiene,
es hat keine Ladung. Also es ist das einfachste Teilchen, das man sich vorstellen kann.
Weiß jetzt noch nicht, welche Rolle das Higgs-Feld und das Higgs-Teilchen noch spielen kann.
Es kann so auch ein, wir nennen es ein Portal, ein Zugang zu der dunklen Materie zum Beispiel sein.
Wenn das Higgs auch an die dunkle Materie koppelt, dann kann das unser Zugang
sein, um die dunkle Materie zu verstehen.
Das Higgs-Feld oder ein Feld mit ähnlichen Eigenschaften wie das Higgs-Feld
kann zum Beispiel auch für die Inflation des Universums verantwortlich sein.
Das haben wir auch noch nicht verstanden.
Warum hat sich kurz nach dem Urknall das Universum inflationär erweitert?
Da ist vermutlich auch ein Feld dahinter und das könnte unter Umständen einige
Theoretiker sagen, das ist das Higgs-Feld selbst, das könnte ein ähnliches Feld sein.
Also das Higgs-Feld, so sehr es das Standardmodell abgeschlossen hat,
kann es auch der Türöffner für neue Erkenntnisse sein.
Und deswegen ist es unser Hauptziel jetzt so viel wie möglich über das Higgs herauszufinden.
Und vielleicht können wir da jetzt einen kurzen Ausblick wagen,
wie kann es am CERN weitergehen.
Genau, darauf würde ich jetzt auch gerne kommen, weil das ist dunkle Materie,
dunkle Energie, das hatten wir hier bei Raumzeit natürlich schon sehr sehr oft.
Das sind einfach zwei von ein paar ganz elementaren Fragen der Physik,
wo man irgendwie weiß, wir beobachten etwas, das nennen wir so,
deswegen heißt es ja dunkel, nicht weil irgendwas wirklich dunkel ist,
sondern weil man es einfach nicht weiß.
So das verhält sich irgendwie wie Materie, man kann quasi die Schwerkraft bei
der Beobachtung des Weltalls feststellen,
aber man kann sie nicht auf die normale klassische baryonische Materie,
die uns sonst überall umgibt und von der wir wissen, dass sie eben diese Schwerkraft
erzeugt, wir sehen diese Materie nicht.
Also entweder gibt es irgendeine andere Materie, deswegen auch dieser Arbeitstitel
dunkle Materie oder eben was auch immer anderes, was dann eben eine entsprechende
Wirkung hat und vielleicht zu der Schwerkraft dazu kommt oder so oder die irgendwie verstärkt.
Und die dunkle Energie, genauso dunkel und unklar,
die halt in irgendeiner Form das Universum ja nicht nur zu dieser initialen
Expansion getrieben hat, sondern ja auch immer noch weiter dazu beiträgt,
dass es sich weiter beschleunigt.
Also wir wissen mittlerweile, dass die Beschleunigung noch weiterhin zunimmt,
zumindest derzeit noch.
Und irgendwann unser Universum so auseinander zerrt, bis wir dann irgendwann
keine Sterne mehr sehen. Dann sind wir zwar nicht mehr hier,
aber theoretisch steht das sozusagen auch noch auf der Liste.
Das sind zwei Themen, die hier sicherlich auch mit eine Rolle spielen.
Und was sind die nächsten großen Ziele noch darüber hinaus?
Aus den Gründen, die ich gerade gesagt habe, dass das Higgs so interessant ist,
sind wir uns, und wenn ich uns sage, dann denke ich schon, die Experimentalphysiker
und die Theoretiker einig, dass wir eine Maschine brauchen, mit der wir das
Higgs besonders genau untersuchen können.
Und mit dem LHC haben wir einen Beschleuniger, der Higgs-Teilchen erzeugen kann,
aber er erzeugt sie in einem sehr schmutzigen Umfeld. Wir schießen ja Protonen
auf Protonen, die bestehen aus Quarks und Gluonen.
Das heißt, bei den Kollisionen selbst ist die Energie der Kollision nicht bestimmt.
Das ist der Nachteil und gleichzeitig der große Vorteil eines Hadronbeschleunigers,
weil es finden alle Experimente beim ganzen Energiespektrum gleichzeitig statt.
Und die Bruchteile des Protons fliegen weiter. Also es ist eine sehr schwierige Umgebung.
Hingegen hätte man einen Elektron-Positron-Kollider, wie der Vorgänger des LHC war,
nur bei höheren Energien, dann kann man die Elektron-Positronen,
das punktförmige Teilchen, Sie erinnern sich, so die Energie so einstellen,
dass Higgs-Bosonen mit viel höherer Wahrscheinlichkeit erzeugt werden und auch
bei genau definierten Energien in einer sehr klaren Experimentierumgebung Und
mit einer solchen Maschine,
wir nennen diese Maschine, an der wir derzeit planen und eine Machbarkeitsstudie machen,
den FCCEE, Future Circular Collider Elektron,
damit könnten wir Higgs-Boson extrem genau untersuchen und vielleicht Hinweise
auf die eine oder andere Frage, die ich vorher aufgeworfen habe,
oder die Sie jetzt aufgeworfen haben, finden.
Das ist dann sozusagen das, was nach dem LHC kommen könnte.
Das könnte nach dem LHC kommen. In der Planung,
in der Machbarkeitsstudie, die wir derzeit machen,
würde das einen neuen Ring bedeuten, mit knapp über 90 Kilometer Umfang,
in dem wir eine solche Elektron-Positron, also wir würden Elektronen auf Positronen schießen,
als Higgs-Factory, das wäre eine Higgs-Factory, Und in dem gleichen Tunnel könnte
man dann, 15 Jahre später, einen noch größeren Hadron Collider einbauen,
der dann zu viel höher in Energien kommt.
Ähnlich wie wir es am CERN schon einmal gemacht haben. Ich habe die Maschine,
den Large Electron Positron Collider, noch nicht erwähnt.
Das war die Maschine, die in dem gleichen Tunnel, in dem jetzt der LHC ist,
installiert war und mit dem man Präzisionsmessungen der Z- und W-Bosonen durchführen konnte.
Wir haben ja zum LHC jetzt noch gar nicht so viele Daten gesagt,
aber das ist ja in dieser Kaskade der Beschleunigerringe, die hier gebaut wurden, der bisher größte.
Und wenn man halt einmal durch die ganze Röhre durchfährt, dann hat man irgendwie
ungefähr 27 Kilometer zurückgelegt.
Das sind glaube ich so knapp vier Kilometer im Durchmesser.
Das liegt hier unterhalb dieses Geländes, an dem wir uns jetzt auch gerade befinden,
teilweise in Frankreich, teilweise in der Schweiz.
Wenn man jetzt diesen FCCE bauen würde mit 100 Kilometer Durchmesser,
etwas mehr als 90, nicht Durchmesser, Entschuldigung, Umfang,
genau, dann müsste man...
Weiter graben. Und wie tief ist der LHC?
In etwa 100 Meter unter der Erde.
Und wie tief wäre dann der Nachfolger? Wäre der noch tiefer?
Der wäre etwas tiefer, aber es hängt natürlich von der Oberflächentopologie ab.
Der Grund für die Tiefe ist nicht,
dass man tief bauen muss, damit keine Radioaktivität austritt oder sonst irgendwas,
sondern damit man in einer bevorzugten Geologie den Tunnel baut,
sogenannte Molasse, die sich leicht bohren lässt.
Das ist der Grund für die Tiefe der Tunnel.
Dass man sich hier nicht durch den Granit fressen muss oder so,
gibt es ja hier auch eine ganze Menge.
Das ist zum Beispiel Teil der Feasibility Study, dass man eine Platzierung des
Tunnels findet, wo sich der Tunnel relativ günstig und mit geringem Risiko realisieren lässt.
Ja, aber das wird noch ein bisschen dauern, glaube ich.
Momentan planen wir den LHC noch einmal kräftig aufzurüsten.
Wir nennen ihn dann den Heilume-LHC. Das passiert jetzt schon und wird dann
im Jahr 2028 abgeschlossen sein und 2029 beginnt dann diese zweite Phase vom
LHC mit deutlich höherer Intensität.
Parallel dazu müssen wir natürlich auch die Experimente umbauen,
damit sie diese höhere Intensität verarbeiten können. Wir bauen dann neue,
bessere Experimente ein, Detektoren ein und dieser verbesserte LHC soll dann
bis etwa 2040-21 laufen.
Parallel dazu könnte man mit den Vorbereitungsarbeiten für den FCC beginnen.
Und? Wird das was? Kostet eine Menge Geld, ne? Nehme ich mal an.
Die Forschung ist natürlich nicht billig. Andererseits ist eine Forschung,
an der alle Länder, die diese Forschung betreiben, mit zahlen.
Mit beitragen und mit zahlen.
Also so gesehen ist es eine sehr
effiziente Art und Weise, diesen Forschungsbereich weiter zu betreiben.
Ja, ich denke, das ist der Vorteil dieses Standorts, dass hier man einfach auch
wirklich zusammenarbeitet.
Ich meine es gibt viel Forschung, die sehr national angelegt ist.
Gibt es überhaupt einen vergleichbaren internationalen Ort zum Zernen,
wo in ähnlicher Dimension gearbeitet wird? Mir würde da jetzt erstmal so,
abgesehen von der Raumfahrt, so nichts einfallen.
Naja, in dem Ausmaß, was die Internationalität anlangt, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Aber in anderen Forschungsbereichen wird schon sehr breit international zusammengearbeitet.
Zu erwähnen wäre vielleicht die Forschung der Gravitationswellen.
Auch hier waren die Resultate nur möglich, weil viele Nationen gemeinsam gearbeitet
haben und über Jahrzehnte das Projekt vorangetrieben haben.
Also es gibt schon Deutschland, USA, Italien und Japan.
Das ist richtig. Und man sieht es natürlich auch,
wie schon erwähnt, in der Raumfahrt, wo halt die ESA ja im Prinzip ähnlich auch
wie auch die ESO schon immer eine sehr internationale und auch schon längst
nicht mehr so europäisch, nur europäische Organisation ist.
Trotzdem ist das Zernen schon noch eine Besonderheit, oder? In den wissenschaftlichen
Organisationen, so wie es aufgestellt ist.
Ja, sicher. Und ich glaube, der Grund ist die Konvention, die eben in den 50er
Jahren geschrieben wurde, die erstaunlicherweise noch so aktuell ist,
dass sie praktisch nicht geändert wird.
Also die Statuten des Zerns? Genau. Eine Änderung wäre jetzt auch wahrscheinlich
fast unmöglich durchzuführen, wenn Sie eine Änderung durch 21 Parlamente in
Europa bringen müssten.
Die Personen, die diese Statuten damals, die Konvention geschrieben haben,
die waren schon sehr sehr vorausschauend und weitsichtig.
Was ist so die Essenz dieser Statuten, die es so besonders machen?
Die Offenheit der ZERN-Forschung,
die Offenheit auch gegenüber anderen Nationen, Standorten, denn zum Beispiel
der ZERN wurde ursprünglich am Standort Schweiz gegründet.
Der Übergang zu einer Anlage, die dann auch in Frankreich sich befindet und
wir haben auch ein ZERN-Gelände in Frankreich, wurde von den Statuten nicht ausgeschlossen.
Der CERN ist mittlerweile seit kurzem auch an Experimenten beteiligt,
die in den USA stattfinden.
Auch das ermöglicht die Konvention.
Also ja, ich glaube, die wurde damals wirklich sehr weitsichtig verfasst.
Immerhin hat sie zu all diesen Erfolgen geführt und wenn man sich den Standort heute anschaut,
live und kicking, ein Ein riesiges Gelände, mit der Straßenbahn hier hingefahren,
die Straßenbahn war so voll, wie viele Stationen wird's wohl dauern,
bis sie dann mal leer ist und wieder Sitzplätze gibt.
Aber es blieb voll und alle wollten dann halt dort zum Zerren.
Und zwar ein diverses Publikum, ein sehr internationales Flair,
was man schon in der Straßenbahn spürt und das ist hier so ein bisschen der
Hauch, der hier durch die Flure weht.
Ja, Herr Krammer, ich würde sagen an der Stelle machen wir mal ein Schlussgespräch
über den ersten Überblick hier über das CERN. Vielen Dank für die Ausführung.
Ja, gern geschehen, hat mich sehr gefreut.
Ja und ich kann nur sagen, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit,
das war jetzt wie gesagt unser erster Blick ins Zern und wir werden uns jetzt die anderen Teile,
die hier noch eine große Rolle spielen, Sendung für Sendung näher anschauen.
Um so ein bisschen dahinter zu kommen, was hier alles gemacht wird.
Ja, bis dann, sage ich Tschüss und bis bald.